okay when you running on inside the
national master school days from spain i
think go for dutch defense I didn't play
that yet I think interesting it shows
some rare line not a bad one but most
people play a g3 was the Dutch and he's
gone for really classical set up with
each III and Bishop d3 and so on okay
let's just finish development here I
think it's a good idea to place you five
in this kind of positions try to get
some pressure on deform it helps to pre
went wide from getting an easy you
foreign okay but is very quickly in the
queenside hmm
hmm this looks a bit inconvenient the
night doesn't have too many squares here
what I don't like us if he takes here
and place to takes d c b c and b 5 this
looks a bit ugly
just the sixth not what I intended
yeah it's got a very nice diagonal now
okay to have seven maybe a five looks
like a sad squirrel yeah why does better
here no question but still should be
fairly solid can try to to block this
you can capture of course yeah he does
capture okay now c5 could be could be
weak let's let's take the a file for a
moment
huh
not quite sure what he's doing here okay
get in the temple
that's not easy not easy at all
check
we had some bit passive but still on
pretty stable I only have the usual time
problems yeah
okay maybe I actually get some activity
here
not sure what position should be okay
it's just that I spent so much time but
it wasn't easy to play night five
morning right at four I was moving more
worried about night f4
very hard to make a move here
I just blown at the Queen okay black
resigns yes was really a bit
inconvenient I think that it should be
okay of course it's expensive but but it
wasn't easy to play with little time
gone on c5 always needs to be covered by
the Queen unfortunately and I cannot
balance position I could play 97 or did
not play 97 hmm gamma K it's a matter of
time just just to time time issue 97
should be still okay i think was
unpleasant though